what about elon himself it sounds like
you spent quite a bit of time with uh
with him what was your takeaway uh as
you did work on the book yeah you know
he was i was talking about a very narrow
sliver of his life right so it wasn't
like
a lot of conversations but it was really
detail-rich conversations around x.com
which was the predecessor company that
you know his half of the predecessor
company that became paypal um and we
spent a lot of time just talking about
like what it was like in those late
1990s like go go internet years you were
talking earlier about adoption curves
right and this was like that was the era
where this was in the water um i think
that the takeaway i have about him
and i'm not certainly not the first i
don't think will be the last to have
this observation is there's a there's a
depth of conviction about the things
that he takes on
that i think is unrivaled in american
business right now like he has tr he's a
true believer in the things he does and
he believes that he has he he believes
deeply in the mission of his companies
uh and that can sound like a really like
like sort of a blase observation it's
different when you see the force of his
personality when you describe something
it's amazing uh and and you know others
have described it but there is this sort
of look in his eye that he is getting to
mars
right like and and and there's a depth
of belief there that just blows you away
so there's this unknown story that you
have about elon musk and how he almost
died uh and obviously the world would
look very very different the
colonization of mars uh space travel
eevee so many different industries would
not be where they are today without elon
musk what's the story as to how he
almost died
yeah so there's actually it's funny
there's two stories of near death wow um
yeah one is in the book and it's it's
reasonably well known though i was able
to get both peter and elon to talk about
it in a bit more depth they
drive together in a mclaren f1 that elon
has purchased after this uh successful
sale of his first company and they're in
a pretty
a pretty vicious car crash uh the car
kind of like jumps up in the air or it
spins around it's totaled and they they
both survive and even people who drove
by who stopped to help one of one of the
people i guess who drove by to stop to
help said something like i wasn't sure
if i should stop because i wasn't sure i
was going to be ready to see what
condition your bodies were in right
so there's that moment of near death and
that's early 2000
a year later
this isn't in the book and it's been
lightly covered in other places
elon
contracts meningitis and malaria and he
doesn't just contract malaria like part
of what i did was i went deep into like
the different kinds of malaria and like
what what they are i really like i said
five years i nerded out on this
he contracts the most virulent form of
malaria it's the one that will basically
kill you within a day if you don't get
treatment and he comes within hours of
death and in fact the person who treats
him at the hospital had treated other
malaria patients who had had the same
type of parasite and both of the
patients that that doctor treated before
elon had died um and so there's this
period in 2001 where for six months you
know he gets sick they are figuring out
what it is at first they diagnosed it as
meningitis then it turns out to be
malaria but he comes within hours of
death and what i had was this kind of
like the executives and the company
sharing their observations about this
the back and forth who's delivering him
flowers have we checked in how's he
doing all of that uh it it is
a very very close shave and he you know
he obviously survives but history could
have been very different if it had gone
the other way i mean that is an
absolutely crazy story and i don't think
one that many people understand just how
close it sounds like he actually was to
dying
yeah to be fair he when he tells it
he'll always he always ends with the
line like that's my lesson for taking a
vacation vacations can kill you
absolutely incredible